hannover damit bei den damen und herren
ist gekommen heute kommt auf einem kanal
jetzt gerade das finale der ebay fehlt
wenn wir allerdings direkt an mit dem
ersten ebay kleinanzeigen angebot und
zwar verkaufte eine person seine
e-gitarre und da fragt man sich jetzt
erst mal hell gitarre da gibt es ganz
ganz viele verschiedene hersteller was
ist die marke die marke dieser gitarre
ist eine gitarre klammer smiley
das ist mein lieblings gitarren
produktionsunternehmen machen wir direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten ebay
kleinanzeigen angebot und zwar ist das
hier das bild davon und im titel steht
hunde katze zugelaufen wer kennt sie
nicht die hunde katzen hunde katze
zugelaufen nicht sicher was es ist
zutraulich wie einst hund aber hässlich
wie einst katze haben es neutral mit
hasen futter gefüttert um es nicht zu
verärgern abholung nur gegen vorlage
eines eigentum nach weises ansicht eine
nette aktion aber ich glaube dass ich
kann nicht sagen ob das ein hund oder
eine katze ist schreibt mir mal die
kommentare was ihr denkt hund oder katze
siehst du das nächste ebay kleinanzeigen
angebot ist eine haribo tüte und man
denkt sich erstmal haye ist sie noch
ganz ist da alles drin ist das ein
besonderer tüte haribo tüte mit nur zwei
gummibärchen ja das sind zwei
gummibärchen drin
nicht mehr lange wenn jemand hängt man
sich dann jetzt erstmal hey vielleicht
verschenkte er das oder 50 cent oder
sony 20 euro würde ich direkt zuschlagen
das nächste angebot ist wahrscheinlich
von einem unwissenden vater eingestellt
worden und zwar ist das ein laufrad ding
sessel von einem baby der schreibt in
den titel nicht irgendwie die marke oder
die bezeichnungen et cetera sondern er
schreibt einfach laufen ging's ja wer
hätte nicht gern einlaufen ding ja
vorhin schon eine runde katze wo man
nicht genau wusste wann setzen hund oder
war das eine katze bei diesem artikel
ist es ein pinguin er sagt aber er
verkauft seine kleine katze
also
[Musik]
direkt weiter und zwar verkauft hier
jemand ganz eindeutig einen
flaschenöffner
er hat sich allerdings anscheinend
vertippt bei dem titel falschen opfer
kupfer
er verkauft also ein falsches opfer aus
kupfer robert was sagst du dazu ich kann
schon so oft nicht messe wird in deinen
videos da habe ich jetzt gar keinen bock
mehr irgendwas zu sagen du fette
arschloch ja hätten wir es auch geklärt
dem nächsten ebay angebot jetzt habe ich
mir wirklich vorher gedacht hey was
meint der eigentlich habe er spiegel
blut ruht das ist das komplette angebot
und ich habe mir erst mal halt gedacht
hey was ist ein blut wut ist das
irgendwie wenn man blut sich auf den
kopf setzt oder keine ahnung was aber
eher in mein blut das ist ein bluetooth
spiegel ist perfekt für anrufe geil das
nächste angebot das auch mal wieder
komplett fair und zwar verkaufte jemand
seinen defekt fernseher für 100 euro
verhandelbaren in der bezeichnung steht
war sehr teuer und plötzlich
runterfallen und meinen sohn kaputt aha
am nächsten der angebot kann ich mir
richtig vorstellen dass das vielleicht
eine ebay eingestellt hat der die
deutsche sprache nicht richtig
beherrschen beziehungsweise noch nicht
alle wörter genau weiß und ich weiß dass
das hier ein sessel es er hat nämlich
einzel holz genannt ja dann wäre das
hier auch eine einzelne bank wo wer
allerdings gerade bereits bei möbeln
sind bleiben wir in diesem gebiet und
zwar er verkaufte jemand seine matratze
in dem titel steht allerdings ich
verkaufen meine mätresse ist 940 - 200
nun verkaufte als nächstes jemand sein
bügeleisen er nennt das ding aber nicht
bügeleisen sondern kleidung dampf und
ich in der beschreibung steht auch
einfach kleidung dampf meine videos
bestehen zu 90 prozent daraus ist
klatsch und irgendwo mein zimmer
herumlaufe
da kennt ihr das wenn ihr irgendwo
hinten sondern habt oder so dann denke
das ist eine spinne dreifachen
herzinfarkt waren allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten ebay
kleinanzeigen angebot und zwar dem hier
das ist eine rennen mülltonne von einem
mülltonnen rennen verschenke wegen umzug
und platzmangel meine rennen mülltonne
da wer hätte nicht gern sonne rennen
mülltonnen wo auch immer die für gemacht
ist wir hatten ja bereits verschiedene
ebay angebot in diesen fünf teilen die
ich mittlerweile von dieser serie
hochgeladen habe und meine damen und
herren wir hatten noch nie die situation
dass jemand ein ganzes land verkauft der
verkauft einfach england auf ebay
grundstücks art sonstige ja ja ich würde
es dann kaufen nun machen wir weiter mit
einem ebay kleinanzeigen angebot was mir
unfassbar häufig gesendet wurde bei
instagram das ist übrigens meinen
insidername verfolgen wollte ich glaub
ich hab schon wie eine spinne im nacken
haben sogar heute neues bild online
die hin stein ins wasser gemacht aber im
endeffekt auf jeden fall hatten wir
bereits verschiedene ekelhafte ebay
kleinanzeigen angebote doch das jetzige
sprengt wirklich den rahmen verkaufe
abgeschnittene fußnägel da kaufe
abgeschnittene fußnägel sind bis zu zwei
jahre alt beste qualität abholungen
augsburg ab nach augsburg ich glaube
eigentlich dass es nudeln sind aber hey
einfach mal als fußwege wird als
nächstes verkaufte jemand auf ebay
seinen drei mal benziner rasenmäher
wer bitte was dafür weiß nicht ob die
funktionieren
genau kennt jedoch diese teile mit so
zweirädern wo man sich drauf stellen
konnte mit den füßen da kommt man so rum
fahren von der marke york waren die
glaube ich die meisten das verkauft
dieser ebay user auf jeden fall ernennt
das ganze allerdings nicht an bord
sondern an das half an bord wenn ich nur
haar verbohrt lesen würde würde ich mir
dass darunter vorstellen machen
allerdings nicht weiter mit dem nächsten
angebot und zwar verkauft hier mal
wieder jemand sein haustier und zwar
eins skeptischer hamster zu verkaufen
er guckt einen skeptisch an als würde
man nichts richtig machen es macht mich
wahnsinnig ich kann diesen
vorwurfsvollen blick nicht länger
ertragen sein name ist olaf ich glaub
dazu muss man gar nichts mehr sagen als
nächstes verkaufte ich jemand sein
portemonnaie ist war schon ein bisschen
dreckig aber dafür ist der ebay
kleinanzeigen da man kann dinge
verkaufen die man schon genutzt hat et
cetera pp es ist jetzt geht nur darum
dass man das ganze richtig betitelt eine
richtige beschreibung rein schreibt und
dieser user hat das ganze portemonnaie
genannt also ich meine ich finds auch
schwierig portemonnaie zu schreiben aber
portemonnaie ist schon komplett daneben
als nächstes verkaufte jemand auf ebay
seinen lieblings tisch für 20 euro hier
oben sehen wir noch ein bild
eingeblendet der user kommt aus
paderborn also tatsächlich bei mir
direkt nebenan man fragt sich allerdings
jetzt hey warum wird er oh mein gott ist
hier viel spucke drauf ja habe ich
gerade hingerotzt herzlich willkommen
auf einem kanal das auch gerne abo darf
als dennoch kein teil der lupus alpha
und wenn das wild
lassen abu dhabis menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend zurück zum tisch
meine lieben freunde er verkaufte er
seinen lieblings tisch und man fragt
sich wenn man doch ein lieblingsziel
warum hat man überhaupt einen lieblings
tisch alter ist aber auch alles komplett
egal auf jeden fall ist es sein
lieblings zwischen man fragt sich hey
warum verkauft der den in der
beschreibung steht aber jetzt nicht mehr
also es ist ein lieblings tisch aber
jetzt nicht mehr
falls sie den kaufen wollt 20 euro
handelbar aus paderborn war allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten angebot
uns was es bedeutet mit dem namen haus k
k für katzen so ein scheiß haus für
katzen ich verkaufe den haus k k für die
katzen
alles klar der gala alles klar
allerdings meine lieben freunde meine
lieben zuschauer wir kommen nun von
allerletzten ebay kleinanzeigen fällt
den ich auf meinem kanal durch
präsentieren werde
dieses einrad es ist ein komplett
normales einrad es kostet 10 euro seht
ihr oben am bildschirmrand schon
eingeblendet aus heidenheim an der brenz
der name ist allerdings ein reifen
fahrrad also
ich
ich werde diese serie irgendwie
vermissen aber die ganzen
rechtschreibfehler werde ich auf keinen
fall vermissen
anders stellt euch das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch dieser letzte teil der
ebay kleinanzeigen feld serie mit luca
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich sehr
sehr dollar einen daumen hoch
freundschaften wir 50.000 live das war
megageil wie gesagt heute der letzte
teil dieser serie schauen wir doch mal
ein bisschen im internet recherchiert
und dabei ist mir aufgefallen dass es
auch extrem viele ebay kleinanzeigen
chat verlauf fails gibt also wo
irgendwelche verkäufer den käufer
beleidigen oder dumme sachen schreiben
etc pp henning bock darauf hätte dass
ich davon eventuell demnächst mal einen
teil hochladen und wir schauen uns mal
zusammen paar chat verläufe anderen
schreibt sie gerne und in die kommentare
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]